pompeux les républicains la parole est à
monsieur de l'iata ma question s'adresse
à monsieur le premier ministre monsieur
le premier ministre
j'associe à ma question jean-pierre door
et mes collègues les républicains de la
commission des affaires sociales nous
avons achevé dans la nuit de vendredi à
samedi l'examen du projet de loi de
santé malgré les demandes répétées de
l'ensemble de l'opposition d'une partie
de votre majorité de reporter l'examen
de ce texte polémique
vous avez imposé son maintien à l'ordre
du jour en dépit du bon sens à tel point
que la généralisation du tiers-payant
points durs qui cristallise l'opposition
de l'ensemble des professionnels de
santé contre votre texte a été discutée
vendredi jour de l'hommage national
rendu aux victimes alors que par respect
les médecins tous ceux qui se posaient
au texte avait arrêté toute action aux
manifestations vous le savez de nombreux
parlementaires que ce soit dans
l'opposition de la majorité était
retenue en circonscription pour des
hommages qu'ils avaient organisée dans
quelques minutes nous allons voter ce
texte au groupe l'est républicain nous
avons dénoncé maintes et maintes fois ce
texte dangereux et le continuerons de le
dénoncer aux côtés des professionnels de
santé
car ils n'apportent pas la réforme
indispensable à la pérennisation de
notre système de santé
pis il contient surtout de très
mauvaises mesures nous sommes contre la
généralisation du tiers payant qui aura
des conséquences inflationnistes sur des
comptes sociaux déjà étranglés et
transforme les médecins libéraux en
fonctionnaires de la santé qui vont
devoir gérer encore plus de paperasse au
détriment de l'otan médical et donc au
détriment des patients
nous sommes contre le paquet neutre est
loin d'être mesures efficaces pour
lutter contre le tabagisme va faire
exploser la contrebande des bandes
parallèles
nous sommes contre la réinstauration
d'un bloc de service public hospitalier
qui rigidifie le système et dresse le
public contre le privé
monsieur le premier ministre la
discussion de ce texte a mis le monde de
la santé en colère et en incompréhension
cela laissera des séquelles son
application s'annonce très difficile
monsieur le premier ministre il est
encore temps de revenir en arrière
la parole est à madame la ministre des
affaires sociales de la santé des droits
des femmes
merci madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
denis jacquat
je vous remercie de votre participation
personnelle constante à l'examen de
textes de loi sur la modernisation de
notre système de santé vous annoncer que
vous même et votre groupe ne voterait
pas ce texte de cette manière vous allez
voter contre la mise en place d'un
parcours éducatif en santé pour les
enfants
vous allez voter contre pour la mise en
place du médecin traitant de l'enfant
vous allez voter contre l'amélioration
des conditions d'accès des femmes à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
vous allez voter contre la mise en place
d'une action de groupe pour les victimes
d'accidents médicaux et vous allez voter
contre par exemple la mise en place du
droit à l'oubli qui va pouvoir
bénéficier à d'anciens malades en
particulier du cancer mais au delà
monsieur le député nous avons sans doute
une manière différente d'appréhender la
situation et de concevoir les choses
vous avez lorsque vous étiez soit
responsabilité mise en place les
franchises médicales
nous nous faisons le choix de faciliter
l'accès aux soins de tout compte de tous
nos concitoyens
grâce au tiers payant généralisé qui se
mettra en place progressivement
vous avez fait le choix de supprimer la
reconnaissance du service public
hospitalier
il y a quelques années nous avons nous
faisons le choix inverse d'inscrire dans
la loi la reconnaissance du service
public hospitalier et nous faisons le
choix monsieur le député de favoriser
l'installation de professionnels partout
sur le territoire national pour répondre
aux besoins de nos concitoyens
vous le voyez monsieur le député par
rapport à certaines mesures dont je
m'étonne que vous ne leur rapporte y est
pas votre soutien nous avons une
approche différente entre en matière
d'accès aux soins de prévention et de
droit à la santé pour tous nos
concitoyens
merci pour le groupe socialiste